Travelers on a plane going to Hawaii had
a sudden mid-air scare yesterday when
this jet hit dangerous turbulence 36
people on a Hawaiian Airlines flight
from Phoenix to Honolulu were hurt as
Carter Evans shows us everybody was
caught by surprise on this one
ladies and gentlemen attention
that plea for help from flight
attendants just moments after a
terrorizing ordeal on Port Hawaiian
Airlines flight 35. my life flashed
before my eyes I was scared the plane
hit severe turbulence which sent some
passengers flying out of their seats the
plane Shook and then like it went into a
sudden drop Kaylee Reyes said her mom
had just sat down after using the
restroom when the turbulence started she
hit the ceiling and she hit the floor
photos show damage to the inside cabin
with overhead panels missing a cracked
ceiling and debris thrown across the
floor we did see patients with head
injuries at least one I believe was for
a Time rendered unconscious paramedics
treated 36 people who were injured on
the flight ranging from 14 months old to
adults 11 of them in serious condition
the FAA is investigating the incident
National Weather Service meteorologists
said the plane may have flown into a
thunderstorm and it could have caused
the turbulence Hawaiian Airlines said
it's working with officials in the
investigation seat belt sign was on at
the time that the incident occurred
there was no warning of this particular
patch of air at that altitude was in any
way dangerous it caught everybody's by
surprise for CBS mornings I'm Carter
Evans
oh never good when even the crew is
caught by surprise but it just seems
like it can hit it no at any time
without warning that is what's so
frightening scariest thing yeah yeah I I
you know you know guys when the
turbulent gets that bad you wonder how
does a plane stay in the air right but
it does it does it is a Wonder to fly I
have ignored that seat belt sign but you
should not definitely should not